well the settlement declaration reverses
the US legal position since 1978 known
as the Hansel memorandum it said
civilian settlements on occupied
territories is inconsistent with
international law in 2017 Trump
recognized Jerusalem as Israel's capital
and a year later opened an embassy there
Washington's policy had previously been
that Jerusalem status wants to be
decided in a peace process and in March
Trump recognized Israel's annexation of
the golden Heights from Syria in a boost
for Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu's
campaign for a second term in power well
let's bring in al jazeera senior
political analyst marvin Bashara he is
joining us live from London and says
that some of the context Marwan on this
administration this president's
determination to reframe u.s. policy
towards the conflict but has he green
lighted the one behavior on the part of
Israel there are many behaviors but
settlement activity that has most
undermined the chances of a political
settlement well yes I think this is
basically the last pillar of the
so-called deal of the century that we
were warned or promised for a couple of
years now that it's going to come out
and I guess there is no point for anyone
waiting for the official announcement of
that deal of the century because as you
just stated in your report already the
main issues that were supposed to come
out in terms of u.s. position on the
solution for Israel Palestine the Trump
administration is clearly and utterly on
the side of the extremist government in
Israel on the question of Jerusalem on
the question of the Palestinian refugees
and on the question of the settlements
and the borders so all in all now we
have a comprehensive u.s. approach to
Israel Palestine where the United States
is a hundred percent on the side of the
Netanyahu government and completely
rejecting every single principle that
the peace process stood on or the
Palestinian Authority advocates and now
it's probably in the Palestinians court
to decide what to do next
what are the options mud one well
certainly the two-state solution that
we've been saying for a while now it's
no longer viable it is certainly not
viable anymore when Secretary of State
Jim Jim Kerry was saying earlier that
this was the last chance and that was
four years ago or three years ago for a
two-state solution that the window is
closed and what the window certainly
closed and now Israel has a green light
to expand even more the Satmar building
with the end of the two-state solution
there are two possible alternatives one
is apartheid meaning Israelis and
Israeli Jewish settlers will continue to
have an upper hand and their own network
of roads and systems and industrial
zones and so on and so forth a superior
one closed one to the Palestinians and
an inferior one where Palestinians live
although indigenous population but in a
disadvantaged position under Israeli
control many think apartheid is not
really much of a permanent solution in
the 21st century so the other
alternative would be the one-state
reality meaning with the maximum
distance of some six miles between any
Israeli and any Palestinian and with the
expansion of the settlements making that
proximity even closer the one-state
reality today is as such that needs to
be recognized by the Israelis and by the
Americans and perhaps advocated for by
the Palestinians and it seems that might
be an ideal situation meaning Jews
Palestinians Muslims and Christians
living all together equally under the
law the law of the land of an Israel
Palestine whereby Palestinians and
Israelis have a right to
self-determination have the right for
democratic elections and have a right
for sovereignty and security I guess
that kind of a solution might be
fair for everyone and I think it would
be supported by much of the
international community the question is
will the rightest government in Israel
accept it it doesn't seem like it at
least at this point in time and Marwan
you know while this is about the US
policy towards Israel and Palestine
domestic politics so always at the top
of trumps agenda
how much does you know legalizing
Israeli settlements play with his
pro-israeli constituencies especially
evangelicals as he campaigns for
reelection I think it's important to
note here because there is a bit of a
misunderstanding around the world about
the question of the Israel lobby it's
interesting that during the Trump
administration the Israel lovely is
mostly unjú Sh not Jewish most of the
Jews in the United States have supported
and voted for the Democratic Party for
many years and over the last election I
think 70 percent of American Jews voted
for the Democratic Party in fact more
Jews voted for Obama and Clinton than
they did for Prime Minister Netanyahu so
what we have today is an extremist
Zionist elite in the East Coast and the
west coast of the United States and
maybe in the rest of the country as well
as an extremist evangelical elite
together making up the foreign policy of
the United States in Israel Palestine
and in fact throughout the Middle East
so it is that extremist right-wing
evangelical as well as extremist cyanus
group that is also you know big donors
to the Trump administration that are
dictating policy fortunately most of
American jewelry is against this kind of
policy most of American jewelry might
end up in the end of the day to be the
bridge for a better more rational more
peaceful US policy towards the Middle
East but that will take a change of
presidency of course but one thank you
as always for your analysis Al Jazeera's
senior political analyst Madeleine
Bashara live in London thank you